it is important to learn the history of
the United States because you can learn
new things about what happened then and
how it is now and how you can change the
world we learn about history so we do it
people mistakes that people have made in
history sometimes history has a lesson
like Abraham Lincoln
saved enslaved people yes I think it
supports know about slavery so there's
nothing like that will ever happen again
it's legal now and it wasn't for part of
Abraham Lincoln's presidency and he
decided nope we can't do this anymore
they weren't treated equally you would
have to get bossed around and came I
don't think anyone should ever be forced
to do something they don't want to do
people shouldn't be just off their color
of this kid whatever color they are that
doesn't matter if she's council
something inside some people are
definitely treated differently sometimes
because of the color of their skin there
was like some riots that happened
recently we just want like happiness
peacefulness and no racism well a statue
is to show thankfulness I think for
remembrance and honor I think the person
that would deserve a statue is Abraham
Lincoln I think Obama John Cena because
he's the most lit person and he can
fight really good
emma watson she stands up for women's
rights and i think that's very good and
important i think people who have made
big changes to the world if someone's
changes last so sure day like Albert
Einstein Martin Luther King he fought
for civil rights and for all of us to be
treated the same way that day
America inside out with Katie Couric
only on National Geographic
that's a tongue twister want more
exclusive content from America inside
out well just click one of these videos
floating next to me